[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 14 novembre bienvenue dans
le 78 sur tv78 voici les titres de
l'actualité le projet est dans les
cartons depuis plusieurs années relié
les routes départemental 30 et 190
entrecher et Triel sur scène avec
notamment la création d'un pont en ant
la scène le pont d'Acher et le nom de
cette nouvelle voie permettrai de
désengorger le trafic dans le secteur
selon le département des Yvelines de
l'autre côté des opposants dénoncent des
nuisances pour les riverins et des
conséquences néfastes pour les espaces
naturels ils étaient plus de 700 à se
mobiliser le weekend dernier vers un
habitat plus adapté pour les personnes
en perd d'autonomie le sujet est
d'importance avec le vieillissement de
la population des solutions actuellement
développées par des entreprises du
territoire étaient présenté aujourd'hui
au Mureau à l'occasion du premier Salon
itonomie Habitat il réunissait 40
exposants à l'initiative des conseils
départementaux des Yvelines et des
hautes scènes ce mercredi c'est la
journée mondiale des écrivains en prison
depuis 2004 plus de 700 auteurs ou
journalistes du monde entier ont été
persécutés pour leurs écrits demain soir
trois d'entre eux parleront de leur
combat pour la liberté d'expression lors
d'une table ronde à la Maison de la
musique et de la danse à la verrière et
dont Somaya ramich poète afghane et
militante des droits des femmes qui a
été contrainte à l'exil interview et
puis c'est l'une des cyberattaques qui a
eu le plus de retentissement il y a un
an l'hôpital mot du chîner au cancour
étaé visé par des pirates informatique
la cybersécurité en jeu de premier plan
également pour les collectivités
françaises attaqué à plus de 200
reprises entre janvier 2022 et juin 2023
et dans les ielines le groupe Orange
accompagne différentes structures sur
cette thématique mais aussi sur celle du
cyber arcellement nous en parlons dans
l'invité du 78 en 2è partie d'émission
et ce sera avec Jean-Luc girud qui est
délégué régional île-de-fance ouest et
Paris à Orange il y a aussi Gabriel
Gontier qui est d'ors et déjà avec moi
en plateau bonsoir bonsoir de la
rédaction de tv78 vous allez nous
présenter dans un instant les
informations en bref à retenir ce mardi
dans les ivblines on parle de quoi et
ben on parlera notamment de la visite de
la ministre de la transition énergétique
agès panieruché elle était en
déplacement dans le département et puis
vous le savez Grégory noël approche à
grand pas on parlera du secrétariat du
Père Noël qui a ouvert aujourd'hui qu'on
va retrouver aussi les logos du 78 sur
tv78 donc les infos du jour ce sera dans
quelques instants dans le dans le
78 désengorger le pont le secteur du
pont de poissie aux heur de pointe un
impératif pour le Conseil départemental
des Yvelines le projet d' 104 bis plus
connu sous le nom de Pont d'Acher doit
enjamber la scène mais certains riverins
et certaines associations dénoncent les
potentielles conséquences de la création
de cette voirie les explication dans ce
sujet de Régine ralèche et de Julien
Leroi c'est un projet vieux de plus de
40 ans le pont d'Acher porté par le
Département des Yveline est prévu pour
2027 il doit relier la route
départementale 190 à Triel sursène et la
RD30 à HR le tronçon se composera d'un
deux fois de voie établissant également
une liaison entre la 13 et la 15 et un
pont de 800 m enjambant la scène c'est
c'est l'un des objectifs et l'objectif
principal c'est de désenclaver la boucle
de Chantelou et effectivement le le
deuxième sujet c'est qu'on va per comme
ça de désaturer la ville de poissi et de
permettre demain aux utilisateurs des
transports en commun qui vont venir
prendre le RER ou le tram T13 à poissi
d'accéder plus facilement qu'aujourd'hui
quand on fait des projets
d'infrastructure il y a toujours des des
gens qui sont gênés parce qu' en
proximité de l'ouvrage mais il y a
beaucoup plus de gens qui vont
bénéficier de cet ouvrage et donc le
politique il est là pour prendre en
compte l'intérêt général coût du projet
200 millions d'euros une phase
préparatoire et des travaux de
déboissement ont d'ors et déjà commencé
mais ce projet est loin de faire
l'unanimité une marche était organisée
ce dimanche 12 novembre pour dénoncer le
projet routier pour la plupart le pont
d'Acher est un problème pour
l'environnement avec ces 40000 véhicules
par jour la pollution pour tout le
territoire notamment via les vents qui
viennent de l'Ouest sur les villes
d'andrésie et
d'Acher c'est 14 % de plus d'émissions
de gaz effet de serre avec ce projet par
rapport à une situation sans projet
c'est la biodiversité qui est parce que
il y a plus de 50 espèces protégées sur
le tracé sur le territoire alors que
l'arrêté préfectorale n'a autorisé que
la destruction que de 30 espèces
protégées pour l'heure un référé
suspension et un recours contentieux ont
été déposés le tribunal de versaill
devrait les examiner dans les prochains
jours le point à présent sur le reste de
l'actualité dans les
ivelines et c'est avec vous Gabriel on
commence avec une visite ministérielle
ministre de la transition énergétique
qui était aujourd'hui à trappe oui vous
l'avez dit la ministre agè Pag runaché
s'est rendu à trappe pour l'inauguration
de l'usine pilote deramet cette usine
est destinée à tester le recyclage de
batteries de véhicules électriques une
étape avant de lancer la construction
d'une usine à plus grande échelle à
Dunkerque aujourd'hui l'entreprise en
partenariat avec le groupe Sue est un
leader européen dans les secteurs
miniers et métallurgiqu pendant sa
visite la ministre a pu rencontrer les
salariés elle a notamment réaffirmé
l'importance de développer
l'indépendance stratégique et
énergétique de l'industrie française
ainsi que son approvisionnement dans une
démarche responsable on l'écoute l'enjeu
c'est notre planification écologique et
la manière dont nous allons développer
des solutions de mobilité électrique sur
le territoire des solutions qui soient à
la portée des Français et qui permettent
aussi de créer des emplois en France de
créer de la richesse en France et de
réindustrialiser notre pays tout en
renforçant notre indépendance
énergétique et notre souveraineté
économique bon un autre dossier où la
France souhaite s'améliorer le niveau
scolaire nos écoliers les derniers
résultats sont plutôt encourageants en
île-de-fance oui vous le savez peut-être
depuis 2017 les nouveaux entrants en 6e
sont soumis à une série de tests au
programme du français mais aussi des
mathématiques le but avoir une idée du
niveau de nos écoliers les résultats de
ces évaluations on été révélés par nos
confrères du Parisien et devinez quoi
Grégory les élèves de l'académie de
Versailles ont obtenu de bons résultats
seissant au-dessus de la moyenne
nationale alors pour vous donner
quelques chiffres entre 2017 et 2023
l'académie de Versailles enregistre une
hausse de 6 points en français et de 4,5
points en mathématiquees l'académie de
Versailles se classe donc 2e nationale
en français et 7e en mathématiques on
voulait revenir à présent sur un
événement qui est gravé dans la mémoire
de nos sapeurs pompiers ivelinois oui
tout à fait souvenez-vous en février
2023 de séisme frappent la Turquie et la
Syrie face à l'ampleur des dégâts les
autorités turques font appel à l'aide
international parmi les 65 sapeurs
pompiers franciliens mobilisés 13 sont
issus des casernes ivelinoises hier les
sapeurs pompiers du département ont
posté une vidéo recueillant les
témoignages de ces hommes et de ces
femmes pour qui cette opération je cite
est gravée à jamais dans la mémoire on
écoute un extrait de leur témoignage je
prends connaissance qu' un séisme en
arrivant la caserne parce qu'on me pose
la question on me dit tu es au courant
qu'il a un séistme et peut-être qu'il y
aurait des équipes éventuell donc voilà
je la prends comme ça par hasard au
charge du matos et on part quoi et donc
on prend un moyen de un bus pour aller
effectivement sur Caraman marage donc on
descend avec le chef de la rescue le
Church et puis moi pour aller faire une
première reconnaissance et en fait là
c'est compliqué parce qu'on est àé par
tout le monde on est tiré de droite et
de gauche on essaie de rester le trinôme
pour pas que qu'on se disperse en fait
ça crie partout ça nous ça cherche à
nous emmener partout et ces gens qui
pleurent et qui nous tirent pour qu'on
cherche à aller aider leur famille ça ça
glace un peu le sang et vous pouvez
retrouver leur témoignage et la vidéo en
intégralité sur la chaîne Youtube des
sapeurs pompiers des ivines on termine
Gabriel avec une actualité plus légère
mais non pas moins sérieuse le
secrétariat du Père Noël est ouvert oui
je vous en parlais en début d'émission
le top des et lancé pour envoyer vos
lettres au Père Noël créé en 1962
l'opération a été mise en place par la
poste alors Grégorie si vous souhaitez
envoyer votre lettre vous avez deux
possibilités sous la forme manuscrite en
adressant votre courrier au Père Noël
sans oublier d'indiquer votre adresse ou
alors de manière informatique sur le
site de la Poste vous avez jusqu'au 20
décembre et bonne nouvelle les lutins
répondent en français et en anglais dans
le département des boîtes aux lettes
vont être installées à l' verrière par
exemple ce sera dès le 27 novembre à
plaisir vous pourrez déposer vos
courriers dès le 1er décembre je vous
conseille de vous rapprocher de vos
communes pour en savoir plus je sais pas
si j'ai été assez sage cette année et
vous PZ essayer je vais essayer aussi en
tout cas merci pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi près de chez vous vous êtes
témoins d'une actualité qui vous fait
réagir dans les evelines n'hésitez pas à
la partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
new garder ses repères et conserver son
autonomie le premier Salon itonomie
Habitat se déroulait aujourd'hui au
Mureau organisé par les départements des
ivelines et des hautes scèes il
proposait des solutions pour maintenir
les personnes âgées à leur domicile
innovation service ou encore financement
un enjeu de taille dans les Yvelines qui
comptera
450000 personnes de plus de 60 ans en
2050 contre 310000 aujourd'hui le
reportage de Julien lurois au moment où
elle sera fatigué elle va avoir la
possibilité de transformer son rollator
en fauteuil roulant
pour une maison plus inclusive la
première édition du salon itonomy habit
se tenait ce mardi 14 novembre à
l'oxygène Factory des Mureau service
aide technique ou financière plus de 40
exposants présentaient des solutions
pour un logement plus accessible pour
les personnes âgées vieillir à domicile
c'est mieux vieillir on voit du monde on
est plus actif et c'est une un des
maillons de notre nouvelle politique du
département des ivelines et des hautes
scèes avec au travers de l'agence
autonomie privilégier le bien viillir à
domicile au détriment de la règle qui
voulit qu'on aille vieillir en
épad en France 90 % des personnes âgées
préfèrent adapter leur logement plutôt
qu'intégrer une maison de retraite selon
une enquête dispositif monte escalier ou
coussin releveur basé à trappe la
société axol propose du matériel
d'accessibilité comme cette rampe
destinée au particulier on peut le
laisser en place toute la journée
c'est-à-dire que la seule chose qu'on a
à faire c'est relever le volet pour
fermer fermer la baie vitrée on n'est
pas obligé de démonter l'ensemble compte
environ 700 € pour cet équipement
facilitant les déplacements du fauteuil
vers les terrasses ou les balcons des
innovations qui ont un cout mais elles
sont éligibles à des soutiens du
gouvernement par exemple ma prime adapte
qui va être mise en place au mois de
janvier qui permet comme ma prime renove
de bénéficier d'aide financière pour
pouvoir adapter son logement
c'est-à-dire transformer une baignoire
en douche et cetera et cetera bienvir
chez soi un défi important à relever le
département des Yvelines est celui où la
population est la plus âgée en
île-de-fance il compteit 310000 seniors
de plus de 60 ans en 2018 et en contrat
450000 en
2050 on ouvre une page culture dans le
[Musique]
78 demain c'est la journée mondiale des
écrivains en prison un événement où la
liberté d'expression sera au cœur des
débats à cette occasion une table ronde
est proposée par le réseau des
médiathèques de 50 ans niveline à
laavrière trois auteurs seront présents
Philomé Robert journaliste haïtien
masbas auteur compositeur congolais
ainsi que la poète afghane Somaya ramich
cette dernière nous parle de son
histoire interview d'Anne Sophie mouek
et de Julien
[Musique]
Leroi
r I a po and writer woman activist from
[Musique]
Afghanistan Afghanistan fall in the hand
of taliban me and my family just FL to
neerland and it's almost two years that
I'm living in neerland with my family
but you know still a part of my life and
part of my family or um in
[Musique]
Afghanistan the story started from the
moment that taliban just baned writing
poetry in Afghanistan then uh i publish
a call uh to all the POS around the
world that please write a POS to
solidarity with the people of
Afghanistan and against
censorship and suppression in
Afghanistan because you know Afghanistan
is the only country that all kind of art
are baned by
[Musique]
taliban this book has such a strong
message for all the people around the
world that be not not
silent when you see lots of
[Musique]
gh when in Afghanistan in
2023 15 of January taliban baned poetry
for POS and also before that they baned
all kind
of kind of in Afghanistan i just
[Musique]
comme tous les mardis une salle du
territoire vous donne trois raisons
d'aller voir sa prochaine date ce soir
la Ferme du Manet à Montini le
Bretonneux nous parle du concert de Ben
loncl le souou pour vous convaincre José
Cachin au micro de Mathilde Francou
bonjour José Cachin je me présente je
suis maire adjoint délégué à la culture
et la vénemciel à la à montinil
Bretonneux et si je suis devant vous
c'est simplement pour vous donner trois
bonnes raisons d'aller assister au
concert de Ben
[Musique]
lonclleou
la première raison c'est que nous avons
très peu de chanteurs de Soule en France
et indéiablement ben lonclle souou fait
partie des meilleurs la seconde raison
c'est que il viendra dans le cadre de
son concert nous présenter son dernier
album et c'est véritablement l'album de
la maturité et enfin ben loncleou c'est
l'assurance de passer une soirée
rassurante apaisée spirituelle et
dansante et ça ça on en a bien besoin en
ce
[Musique]
moment je viens donc de vous donner
trois bonnes raisons d'aller voir le
concert de Ben L'Oncle souou si vous
êtes intéressé si vous souhaitez
partager ce moment avec nous c'est un
concert qui se déroulera à la ferme du
Mané le 25 novembre à
20h30 et puis ces images de concert le
rappeur inimontin kururta se produisait
sur la scène de la Fabrique vendredi
dernier à bois d'Arc un événement à
guichet fermé 300 personnes ont fait le
déplacement pour ce dernier concert de
l'artiste comme indépendant kurta va
rejoindre officiellement un label
musical d'ici la fin de l'année livelino
a interprété ses principaux titres dont
petit où il revient son sur son parcours
personnel regardez cet
extrait tu seras pas unfant
popula tuas dans l'ééche
scolaire très peu d'entre eux te
tendront vraiment la
main tant
pis tu te rattacheras très vite à
l'écriture trouvera un surnom en
signature créera un personnage en guist
mure tout le monde
s tu
[Musique]
rêveras d'être un grand
homme une belle
personne aimer
respecter
[Applaudissements]
tu d'être un
grand
[Musique]
éc et pour ce concert nous avons suivi
kurta sur scène et en backstage pendant
plusieurs heures un numéro d'une journée
avec qui vous sera proposé très
prochainement sur tv78 juste avant
l'invité du 78 coup d'œil aux prévisions
météo de
demain et on continue cette semaine avec
des températures plutôt douces pour la
période demain matin quelques rayons de
soleil également au menu dans les
ivelines compté 11 degr à mont-elajolie
10 à versaill du côté de Houdan 9°gr
sont attendus tout comme à Rambouillet
même temps pour l'après-midi et un peu
et peu de changement du côté des
températures il fera 12°gr à Rambouillet
ou dans et Versailles un petit degré de
plus à manentel jolie et ses alentours
avec 13 degr ce mercredi 15 novembre je
vais y arriver nous fêterons les Albert
tout de suite l'invité du
et notre invité c'est Jean-Luc girud
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes le
délégué régional Île-de-France ouest et
Paris pour le groupe Orange et avec vous
on va parler de deux sujets sur lesquels
le groupe est justement engagé la Cyb
sécurité et le cyberhcèlement des sujets
qui sont régulièrement au cœur de
l'actualité dernièrement vous êtes
engagé auprès de collectivités
d'entreprise de club de sport et Mme
auprès de particulierers on aura
l'occasion d'en parler tout d'abord une
première question est-ce que les les
risques cyber on parle beaucoup de
risques cyber sont en forte progression
ces dernières années oui c'est en forte
progression et surtout aujourd'hui
autant les gens se posaient des
questions de savoir s'ils allaient ou
pas être attaqués aujourd'hui non vous
allez être attaqué la grande question
c'est est-ce que vous êtes bien protégé
est-ce que vous êtes bien en position de
pouvoir restaurer vos données et rouvrir
vite en terme de continuité de service
le sujet donc il faut bien se préparer
aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça que Orange
cyberdéfense a des offres pour les
individus id les pouros les PME les
entreprises alors sur la Cyb sécurité
justement de chiffres à donner près de
200 cyber atttaques ont été recensé
auprès des des collectivités françaises
contre des collectivités françaises
entre janvier 2022 et juin 2023 dans les
ivelines des communes comme ouille ou
encore Sartrouville en ont fait la mer
expérience et un chiffre à donner aussi
côté particulier un français sur qu
estime recevoir un message suspecté
d'être une tentative d'arnaque au moins
tous les jours l'état des lieux dans les
ivelines en île-defance c'est c'est à
peu près le même on est aussi sur un
phénomène qui est qui est en
augmentation c'est un phénomène qui est
en augmentation et puis nous on le voit
au niveau de la France au niveau niveau
des ivelines mais vu qu'on a un
opérateur international on a tous les
grands backb les grandes liaisons et
donc on s'aperçoit et on suit tous les
virus qui passent et donc on les voit
monter en puissance ce qui permet de
préparer nos entreprises et de manière
queyber défense puisse apporter des
bonne protection sur la protection des
données auprès des des entreprises c'est
important pour Orange on veut absolument
que les gens vivent bien
digit il faut que soz sen protég et pas
vous sen comme vous dites menacé par des
mail un Français sur 4 c'est quand même
beaucoup donc voilà c'est des choses
qu'on essaie de de réduire mais
paradoxalement si jamais on parle avec
les entreprises on s'aperçoit que les
entreprises sont sensibles et les
patronsentrepris sont sensibles sur le
sujet pratiquement l'intégralité mais il
y en a moins de la moitié qui ont pris
en compte on comptait voir pour mettre
des protections antivirus DESS et autes
en cons c'est pas prise en compte enc
aujourd'hi c'est pas encore pris c'est
pas encore suffisamment pris en compte
je pense qu'ils savent pas toujours
comment ça doit se passer où est-ce
qu'ils doivent le faire c'est quand même
un petit investissement mais bon c'est
un antivirus pour quelqu'un c'est la
moitié d'un du prix d'une pizza donc
voilà donc il faut savoir relativiser
parce que on regarde à peu près sur
quand vous avez une entreprise qui a été
attaquée dans 60 % des cas dans les 6
mois elle a mis la clé sous la porte
ouais elles sont très fragiles si elles
font face à ce genre de de cyber attaque
Gabriel vous aviez une question vous
parliez des entreprises il y a aussi
beaucoup de particuliers qui sont
attaqués qu'est-ce que cherch les
cyberattaqueurs ah bah globalement plus
si je récupère toutes des données chez
vous et que je récupère vos bot de passe
très très facilement benah je peux aller
sur votre compte bancaire parce qu'on
souvent les gens ont le même mot de
passe pour plus endroits c'est pas bien
les jeunes se sentent super attaqués
mais c'est eux qui sont les plus faibles
sur les mot de passe et sur sur la
protection de leurs données alors que
les gens plus âgés qui sont moins
sensibles ont ont des des pourcentages
on le voit dans la population plus
important entre 80 % sont couverts avec
des mots de passe qui peuvent changer
avec des antivirus alors que les jeunes
sont plusuttour de 40 % donc c'est c'est
c'est paradox paradoxal mais vraiment si
je récupère vos données bah après je
vous dis bah vous me donnez un peu
d'argent pour que je puisse vous libérer
votre compte ou alors je vais dire des
choses et je vais faire des spams à
partir de truc donc voilà c'est c'est du
chantage c'eston appelle du rançon des
rançons ouverts donc voilà c'est
globalement il chercheent à avoir des
données pour pouvoir vous faire chanter
ou alors récupérer plein de données qui
peuvent revendre sur le Dark web et en
conséquence bah va pouvoir faire des
actions sur le sujet ou ou même attaquer
des des des endroits en passant par
autres ordinateur puisque ça donne des
puissances informatiques donc oui
l'individu est autenplé que les
entreprises al il y a un événement qui a
marqué les consciences dans les evelines
c'était il y a un an l'hôpital André
Mignot du chîner au concours était visé
par des pirates informatiques on se
souvient l'établissement avait dû être
bloqué son fonctionnement avait été
bloqué pendant plusieurs semaines voilà
il y a ce genre d'incident et a aussi on
disait tout à l'heure les collectivités
qui sont viser comment aent justement
est au côté de ces collectivités de ces
établissements dans cette prise en
compte du sujet cybersécurité alors dans
les cas que vous citez he orange chber
défense est venu accompagner les gens
mais quand vous arrivez après l'incident
vous êtes là en train de protéger
d'esserer faut le faire en amont de
manière que vous ayez bien vos
sauvegardes qui ont été faites que vous
avez bien prévenu les plans de
continuité de service pour pouvoir
remonter en sur le sujet sinon ça peut
prendre des temps vous parliez des des
différentes personnes ça a pris 6 mois 2
ans et je suis pas sûr que tout soit
encore revenu complètement sur le sujet
avec des coûts très importants parce
qu'il faut commencer à côté quand d'un
seul coup vous avez au niveau d'une
collectivité parce que ça peu près 23 %
des collectivités aujourd'hui qui sont
attaqué qui sont concernés par les
attaques informatiques euh et ben d'un
seul coup pouvez plus aller sur la
cantine vous pouvez plus réserver la
crèche euh c'est les données bancaires
que vous aviez quelque part et ils les
ont prises ils vous font chanter en
disant bah c'est vous vous me payez pas
je les mets sur le Dark web et donc
personne pour utiliser donc c'est
vraiment des c'est un effet boule de
neige ça ça des conséquen sur plusieurs
sujets alors l'autre sujet justement
dont on voulait parler avec vous c'est
celui du cyberhcèlement c'est aussi une
thématique d'importance notamment auprès
des jeunes il y a quelques jours c'était
la journée nationale de lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire un harcèlement qui
bien sûr se poursuit maintenant à la
maison avec le le poids de plus en plus
présent des réseaux sociaux un chiffre
aussi à cité une famille sur quatre a
déjà été confronté à des cas de de cyber
harcèlement là encore c'est un un
phénomène que vous vous constatez en
augmentation on parlait de cybécurité
enfin cyber attaque là cyberhcèlement
aussi le harcèlement vous voyez un petit
peu dans dans les chroniques de la
société c'est pas juste sur sur la
partie internet c'est c'est un phénomène
qui est plus une tendance au niveau de
la société malheureusement et vu que
nous on a quand même cette volonté de
dire je veux que les gens vivent bien le
digital et qu'ils soient à l'aise sur le
digital et ben donc on on cherche à
sensibiliser et éduquer les personnes
sur sur le sujet donc on a fait une
opération le mois dernier donc c'était
carton rouge aussi be racellement comme
vous disiez tout à l'heure on a fait des
des opération avec des clubs de foot et
des clubs de rugby en particulier sur
les des ateliers numériques des ateliers
numériques où on on explique aux gens
qu'est-ce que c'est le harcèlement vu
que on fait ça avec les les clubs
sportifs c'est leur coach qui explique
le sujet c'est la voix de Dieu pour les
enfants donc ils écoutent vraiment les
coach enant s'aperçoivent qu'il y a
quelqu'un qui est dans une situation un
peu désagréable quand ils les font
parler donc ça permet de vraiment
d'identifier des des situations
importantes on l'a fait à bûchel on l'a
fait à Fontenel fleur enfin il y a si ou
SEP clubs qu'on a pu faire comme ça sur
sur les Yvelines on voit une vidéo avec
que Fontenel fur vous disiez les les
enfants oui comment ils réagissent
comment ils accueillent justement ces
ces ateliers en fait on les fait parler
enfin une fois qu'ils ont compris
l'atelier c'est important finalement de
parler ils commence à parler et c'est là
qu'on s'aperçoit enent ils parle d'une
autre personne mais en fait c'est eux
qu'on subit quelque chose leur coach en
prend conscience et donc va les
accompagner et les faire parler ou voir
avec les parents sur le sujet donc c'est
vraiment des des choses qui sont qui
sont importantes à peu près là sur la
sur la France là on a fait à peu près
55000 sensibilisations auprès de
d'enfants ça fait à peu près 300 sur les
Yvelines donc parce que c'est donc c'est
vraiment des des phénomènes lourds et
sur lequel on sent pour nous orange
c'est vraiment important cette situation
c'est inacceptable de de que les gens
soient harcelés donc on essaie de mettre
en des moyens en place on fait un peu la
guerre par rapport à ça et c'est c'est
une volonté importante pour le groupe
que vous soyez à l'aise avec les outils
que Orange peut proposer une dernière
question va peut-être voir aussi
quelques ressources s'afficher pour
justement les victimes de C harcèlement
pour qu'elle puisse être aidé est-ce
qu'il y a des projets en la matière de
nouveaux projets qui vont être développé
dans dans les prochaines semaines de
prochaines collaborations peut-être
alors déjà on met à jour t tous les
antivirus tous les T tous les les les
les logiciels qu'on peut proposer que ça
soit au niveau des individus ou que ça
soit au niveau des entreprises ça on le
met à jour on s'assure que ça soit
toujours bienveillant mais surtout aussi
on a des des sites web on a bien vivre
le digital pour que les gens puissent
voir un peu comment ça se passe
vis-à-vis des enfants vous avez un
numéro de téléphone qui est le 3018 qui
est complètement anonyme si jamais vous
pouvez quand même expliquer vous êtes
victime d'un ass harcèlement et donc qui
sera là pour vous vous accompagner vous
Saez il y avait un autre numéro qui
était le 3020 pour les problèmes à
l'école ça va fusionner je pense euh les
deux numéros en début d'année prochaine
donc le 3018 sera vraiment la base pour
que tout le monde qui qui subit une
pression puisse se défendre et Orange il
va sur le sujet sur les jeux même sur
comme fortnite on a fait des safe zones
pour que les gens puissent s'isoler en
conséquence donc oui on multiplie les
dispositifs pour apporter euh une
protection au au niveau de ça et et on
est constamment euh en train de faire
des choses nouvell parce que vous
parliez de lunivè des gamers c'est plus
de 20 % d'entre eux ont déjà été
victimes de cyberhcèlement et
l'important c'est d'en parler on a vu
quelques ressources s'afficher pour être
aidé si jamais on est victime de
cyberhcèlement merci en tout cas
Jean-Luc girud d'être venu de parler de
ces sujets en plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes le délégué régional Île de
France ouest et Paris du groupe Orange
merci également à à Gabriel Gontier de
m'avoir accompagné sur cette demi-heure
d'émission voilà c'est la fin du 78
merci de votre fidélité nouvelle édition
dès demain et ce sera avec Mathilde
Francou à la présentation belle soirée
sur tv70
[Musique]